[Music]
always looking for new faces and take my
car please Terry Donaldson the fashion
photographer so how much you pay to take
my picture I'll give you the money let's
play for the picture we do this right
change your life why do I want to do you
I'm not being model is better than being
cleaning lady can you walk
yes I walk long way to Mogadishu yes
hideous hideous take them all
[Music]
you're a top model everybody adores tell
me about the day that changed your life
if I tell you a story you guarantee me
I'll be published
[Music]
[Applause]
you think about her a lot and for
anything
there's a proverb in my country whatever
happens to the least of us has an effect
on all of us let us try and change what
that means to a woman
[Music]
[Applause]